we'll go ahead and get started so want
to welcome everyone to the first said is
that an echo anyways I want to welcome
everyone to the first exit of two
proposal defenses today one masters and
one dissertation and I don't know what
the food plans are for the second one
I'll let them figure that out anyways so
for those who are new to our informatics
graduate program proposals basically the
candidate gives an overview of his or
her project proposal for either thesis
master's thesis or PhD dissertation and
we there's then there's a presentation
some public comments then the public is
dismissed leaving behind the committee
and the candidate who may ask further
questions and then the candidate is
dismissed and the committee decides
whether the student is ready to move on
to their thesis or dissertation and will
repeat this process at 2 o'clock today
with Nathan our come on in our master's
thesis proposal candidate today is Brian
Laraway who has a bachelor's degree in
biology from Reed and has done a number
of things in cellular molecular biology
and now is seeking a Master of Science
degree in the bioinformatics and
computational biology track so I will
let him go from here and we have the
full committee here now all right thank
you very much okay so yeah today I'm
going to talk about my master's thesis
proposal I'm going to be looking at a
few different tools for identifying
model organism models of a he
and diseases looking at both the model
models of disease and also Jean
candidates of human diseases and as bill
mentioned here's a little bit about me a
research here at OHSU in the ontology
development group which is part of the
what you see a library
I am a data Wrangler for the monarch
initiative that's the key project I work
on where we're looking for along similar
lines were trying to identify models of
diseases and model organisms and
identifying gene candidates for
undiagnosed diseases and as mentioned
them obviously a graduate student here
in the bioinformatics and computational
biology track Indy mice and then I also
have a previous computer science
training at AIT and then that biology
degree from Reed College and I wanted to
start off talking a little bit about
diseases in humans and you know just
differences between you know common
diseases and rare diseases and you know
things in an example of a few of the
common diseases you know would be things
like diabetes and Alzheimer's you know
you get you have about you know a
prevalence of a 1 out of 10 people you
know might be diagnosed with these
diseases but then you have some more
rare diseases and these are Mendelian
diseases such as cystic fibrosis in
which the prevalence is lower and as you
can see going down the slide there the
the incidence of those diseases you know
gets smaller and smaller to the point
where in the case of ribose 5-phosphate
isomerizes deficiency there was actually
only one patient ever diagnosed with
that disease which would be about as
rare as you can get for human diseases
and then of course just a little on
undiagnosed diseases these are diseases
for human patients so you know we don't
know what the causes for the disease yet
and we don't have any gene candidates
and we're not really sure of the
prevalence it might be more that might
be just one person it might be more than
one um well we don't really know until
we really dive in and find exact out
exactly what's going on with the disease
what the underlying cause of the disease
is so the goal of my proposal um again
is to identify animal models of human
diseases and then also identify gene
candidates for those human diseases and
so the question the question I'm trying
to answer here is you know how do you
really find you know a model of a
disease model of a human disease in a
model organism how can you determine
you know if the phenotypes II might see
presented here you know for example you
know what BCD would be a phenotype you
know how exactly are you sure that that
you know is similar expression of that
phenotype in a model organism such as a
mouse or a zebrafish and one of the key
ways to go about this is to you know
compare those phenotypes between
organisms so if if you're looking at a
particular disease in humans and the
example I have here is for a lustrum
syndrome you know a few a few of the
disease's a few of the phenotypes that
make up the phenotypic profile profile
of that disease would be obesity and
diabetes mellitus and insulin resistance
and if you look at similar animal models
you could see that you know you have
similar phenotypes represented there as
well such as for the mice you have
increased food intake hyperglycemia and
insulin resistance and then in the
zebrafish also you'd have increased
weight at a post increased adipose
tissue volume and then issues with a
glucose homeostasis and you can see just
a just in between those three models
the terminology used for each of those
phenotypes is a little bit different you
know going from one organism to the next
so the question is when you're trying to
relate these models across species you
know how do you determine you know
computationally that those phenotypes
are similar you know you and I you know
can take a look at that you know just
visually and we can tell you that yes
you know I mean those all sound the same
but if you're trying to do string
matching in a computer you won't be able
to retrieve those exactly without some
additional help but um but the key but
the key here is to consider the concept
of phenotypic profiles so if you if you
take a genotype or disease you'd say
that you know either one of those would
be associated with a set of phenotypes
and the full set of phenotypes
associated associated with that genotype
or disease would be called the
phenotypic profile for that genotype or
the disease and you can also do that for
specifically gene variants as well if
you want to say kind of like a genotype
with a single gene variant would be kind
of equivalent so the question is if you
have these two phenotypic profiles for a
disease and a genotype or gene variant
and you want to look at them across
species how do you - how do you
determine that those phenotypes are
related
and in my bowls I'm gonna look at two
different methods for determining you
know the the FINA cross-species
phenotype relations now the first tool
that I want to discuss is Allison
Allison uses provides semantic
similarity metrics for phenotypes and
basic it uses a it takes in phenotype
annotations along with ontology ontology
is being a controlled vocabulary
describing a domain of knowledge that
includes a hierarchy so you can reason
it up and down the hierarchy to more or
less specific terms and what you would
do is in the case you know a human
disease in a mouse the genotype you
would take the phenotype annotations
that make up the phenotypic profile for
the two organisms and you can see you
know on the Left we have human phenotype
ontology terms for the human disease and
then on the mouse side we have mammalian
phenotype ontology terms and you need to
find the common term between the two and
what Allison will do using the ontology
it will reason between those two between
phenotype pairs and determine what the
what the the the the bridging the
bridging phenotype term wouldn't be so
it might have to it would have to move
potentially have to move to be less
specific term in order to get a match
but using the ontology its able to
reason across the differences in anatomy
and physiology and those species
specific terminologies to determine you
know what that linking phenotype would
be and Allison will provide a set of
semantic similarity scores based on just
you know how rare the the frequency that
those terms might be present for the
phenotype descriptions of the organism
so using this approach if we can
determine you know that the set of
phenotypes and the phenotypic profiles
between the two species are semantically
similar we can then infer that the
genotype is a representative model of
the human disease or also for the single
variant gene might also be a ma a
candidate for that human disease now the
the awesome approach does have some
strengths and strengths and we
this is one of the one of the key
strengths is that it does not require a
matching of ornithologist genes in order
to identify these similar phenotypes
phenotypic profiles across species so
when the benefits there is that if you
have a phenotype that is two phenotypes
that are similar but they don't involve
mutation of the exact same genes but
perhaps instead mutations of genes in
the same biological pathway and you
could then return those phenotypes it's
similar even though you know they aren't
direct match so that that might be a
good way to explore you know other genes
and other pathways that you know might
influence you know similar phenotypes so
if you're trying to diagnose an
undiagnosed disease it can kind of
broaden the scope of you know the
genotype the genes and pathways that you
might want to investigate one of the one
the drawbacks though is that I mean it
does require sufficient phenotype
annotations and also requires sufficient
integration of cross species of
phenotype ontology is between organisms
and then of course take some curator
time and in and so it can be a learning
rate limiting step if you want to add
new species to to your comparisons and
then and then finally if you if you're
looking at genotypes of diseases that
have phenotypes it manifests in a
different way especially and dissimilar
organisms say if you wanted to want to
find a model of human disease of yeast
since you have no Anatomy to really
compare with you know you're gonna have
a much greater much larger barrier to
identifying a similar phenotypes
phenotypic profiles so this is where the
other tool comes in into play I'm FINA
logs the work done here they describe
phenol logs as the extension of gene
orthology to ornithologist phenotypes
and how this is done is you basically
take you examine two phenotypes in two
different organisms and you take the
list of genes that are associated with
the phenotype and you search between
those gene lists and identify
ornithologist and gene matches and if
your phenotypes have are enriched for um
for those fourth Oligocene matches you
can you perform a in a Richmond
calculation using a hyper geometric
probability calculation and you can then
get a determine whether or not there's
significant enrichment that determine
whether or not you can consider the two
phenotypes between the species to be
ornithologist one of the problems with
this is just if we want to compare
phenotypic profiles note that this
approach is only doing single phenotype
to phenotype comparisons so in order to
compare phenotypic profiles where we
have multiple phenotypes we will need to
extend this algorithm to look to do
another enrichment calculation and this
time looking for enrichment of
identified fina logs between the
phenotypic profiles of a human disease
and a model organism genotype so kind of
similar to the previous enrichment
calculation step would be doing the same
thing here but instead of looking for
enrichment of our thalamus genes were
looking for enrichment of orthologous
phenotypes and then in the work that
that the groups did that towards us
towards this approach they also
developed a map and improve method for
identifying gene candidate predictions
using these ornithologist phenotypes and
how they did this is what they would do
is they would create a matrix gene the
phenotype association matrix and so
anywhere on the match for each species
and anywhere on the matrix EC a diamond
here would be a there would be in it
there'd be a known association between a
gene and a phenotype and what you do is
you combine multiple multiple gene
phenotype associates Association
matrices and compare them between
organisms and if there's a phenyl log
identified between those species for
that phenotype so if if phenotype one
here for humans mice and zebrafish if
those if that's a known set of a phenol
logs you could then look at the genes
that are associated with each phenotype
in each organism and look for um spots
you know where you don't have an
Associated gene gene and one organism
but it is present in the other so the
fact that gene E is present is
associated with phenotype one in
zebrafish and mouse would then give a
stronger prediction for that same gene
possibly being associated for phenotype
one in humans and it might just be that
for whatever reason you know the state
of the researchers hadn't made that
Association yet
so the strengths and we strengthen
strengths and weaknesses of this
approach one of the largest things is
that you know we can identify
non-obvious phenotype pairs since the
approach does not require really any
information specifically about the
phenotype and instead works through gene
ornithology we can identify you know
phenotypes that prevent have have
different manifestations and then of
course as I just showed you with the
gene candidate them the matrix based
gene candidate approach we can
incorporate data from multiple species
at once in our gene predictions for
human diseases one of the drawbacks is
that it does require the prep the
identification of gene ortholog so if a
specific species you want to work with
het doesn't have a lot of orthologs
identified across species and that could
be a problematic for the analysis and
then it does not account for the network
effects that we might capture with the
Allisyn approach where whereas this
approach we're looking specifically at
the mutation of ornithologist genes
whereas the Allisyn approach could
capture more than Network mutations that
occur in the network and then finally
well the biggest limitations is just a
gene phenotype associations you know
we're finding quite a few of them in
different model organisms but you know
the experimentation that can be done in
humans is obviously less so the number
of gene phenotype associations and
humans trails behind that in model
organisms so with all with all of this I
have a two different specific aims and
the for a specific game one I'm gonna
use these two different approaches in
just Mouse humans and zebrafish I'm just
limiting it to three organisms that I
have good ontology integration so that I
get an equal comparison between the
Allisyn approach and the phenyl log
approach and then for my second specific
aim I'm going to do an extended extended
search using phenyl logs looking for
Canada genes and model models of human
diseases and for this one I'm going to
just grab as much I'm gene phenotype
Association data as I can get my hands
on that I can clean and scrub within the
time frame that I have to do my thesis
work and one of the really cool things
is you know they did for every
additional you know species that I add
um it'll just strengthen beguine gene
candidates that I get at the other end
just a little bit on the work flow so
for for the awesome approach for
identifying human models of disease
models of human diseases and model
organisms I would basically take the
phenotype annotations for the phenotypic
profiles of human diseases and model
organism genotypes and combine those
with the species specific ontology in
order to relate across species and feed
those into the Allison package which
will then return the various semantic
similarity metrics for the proposed
human human disease and model organism
genotype matches and then likewise for
the gene candidates similar similar
approach on the only difference here is
that instead of using model organism
genotype phenotype phenotypic profiles
I'll be using the specific like single
gene phenotypic profiles and then for
the phenyl logs approach as mentioned
before it's a little bit a little more
complicated here because I do have to do
two subsequent enrichment calculations
the first one being looking for
enrichment of ornithologist genes
between phenotype pairs and then the
second one I'm being looking for
enrichment of phenyl logs between
phenotypic profiles and there I'd be
feeding in the human disease phenotypic
profiles in the model organism genotype
phenotypic profiles to get to my model
organism gene genotype candidates and
then for similarly for the gene Canada
predictions for humans I'll stuff in the
au combination combination step here as
well where I'll be taking my gene
phenotype Association data performing
the algorithm with the matrix based gene
candidate extension which will provide
gene candidates for single human
phenotypes which I will then have to
combine together for gene candidates for
multiple phenotypes into the phenotypic
profile that would match the phenotypic
profile of the human disease and that
would then provide me my full I'm gene
candidate set for that human diseases
phenotypic profile and I'm gonna be
doing a bunch of different evaluations
just some of the really basic ones
exploratory data analysis you're looking
at the total total models that are
retrieved done by each method looking at
you know which models are retrieved just
by one one method versus the other
and then I'll be doing them I'll be I'll
be graphing the scores that I obtained
from each method - it'll be very
interesting to see if there are models
of diseases that are found to be scored
highly by one method but you know poorly
by another are gonna do some additional
analysis to kind of take a look at those
and figure out exactly what they are for
example if if they're if a model is
scored high by Alison only I can use a
functional internet functional
interaction Network gene interaction
Network a tool known as gene mania to
kind of look at the networks that are
involved in in that model to kind of get
an idea you know exactly why that one
only was captured by Alison and not by
the the fina log approach and then for a
phenyl only I do a manual examination of
those phenotypes you know just to figure
out you know why the semantic similarity
methods you know we're not we're not
able to capture that model and it I just
might be insufficient annotation you
know insufficient ontology and
integration or it could very well be you
know a very dissimilar you know
manifestation of phenotypes between the
species and then of course also do kind
of like a QA test where I will be taking
a certain models of human diseases these
are models and of human diseases and
model organisms that have you know kind
of considered the the best candidate
models of human diseases and seeing if
which methods you are able to retrieve
successfully retrieve those models and
then for the gene candidate approach I'd
be comparing the gene candidates for the
phenotypic profiles and looking at
looking at the rankings that are
produced by each method and as well as
doing some additional gene mania
analysis to still look at the
interaction networks that may be present
between via say like the top twenty you
know rank genes and then also for any um
human diseases that have known gene
associations I would then search the
rankings to find out you know where
exactly those known genes turn up in the
gene Canada rankings um so for example
for phenylketonuria hopefully you know
the key gene that's involved with that
would be right at the top okay so some
of the anticipated results I've kind of
touched on that a little bit just based
on you know what the evaluations been
doing but you know I will be expecting
you know that the the two methods will
have an overlapping identification of
models and that each method will also
you know exclusively identify you know
certain models of human diseases and
then that that um Allison will be able
to capture ones that don't rise by Gina
orthology whereas the female Express
would be able to capture additional
models that aren't semantically similar
and then the additional pathway gene
candidates for a house and also expect
that the gene candidates retrieved by
the females approach would be more
highly conserved based on their the
requirement for gene ornithology and one
of the other interesting questions that
will kind of come up and unfortunately
I'm only doing at two organisms in
addition to humans by the question of
you know as the phylogenetic distance
increases between the two organisms
being compared will the reach the
percentage contribution of one method
versus the other change over time and I
would I would expect that for
comparisons that are closer together and
in regards to phylogenetic distance will
probably have a greater contribution of
Allison but if we get further and
further apart we probably see a larger
contribution through the phenyl log
method
hopefully that will be a parent you know
in comparing in a human mice and
zebrafish but if if I had the
opportunity to do you know do some a
single celled organism like yeast that
might be more apparent and then of
course the other important step you know
just a question of which if whether or
not both methods will be able to
sufficiently retrieve the evaluated
models of human diseases and hopefully
the Ligurian section will be more
covered by the Allison and phenyl hikes
there and then also you know looking at
the gene Canada ranking this essay as I
mentioned before um you know I'll be
taking a look at the seeing exactly how
those shake out and then for you know
like for diseases that do you have the
known no known associated genes
hopefully that they will show up in the
top candidates by both approaches and
then for aim to doing my extended search
using the phenyl log approach obviously
with the addition of additional
organisms I'll be expecting to be
obtaining additional model organism
models of human diseases and then also
being I'll be expecting to grab you know
a broader and stronger gene predictions
by using multiple organisms at once
and then my timeline for this work I'm
hoping to you know in about a month be
able to get all via data acquisition and
ontology preparation done get everything
prepared and and start doing the actual
coding and hopefully coding planning I'm
doing about a hopefully we'll take about
a month and then I have about two months
scheduled you know for a data analysis
and you know just seeing exactly what I
got and then after that additional two
months for the writings and defense and
so in summary um you know what I hope to
do is use these two different methods to
identify models of human diseases and
candidates for human diseases and you
know hopefully and I'll be using the
semantic similarity approach of the
house and the extension of gene
ornithology for fetal and I'll be
comparing and comparing and contrasting
those two approaches and I'd like to
thank my committee who's been very
supportive through all of us and of
course the monarch initiative OHSU
ontology group and HSE library and of
course D mice family friends colleagues
past and present thank you so I have a
question let me just remind those who
are new to our conference series if you
when you ask the question hold down the
buttons so the so your question gets
recorded I maybe I missed this is is
there a gold standard I mean what's your
metric for comparing your rate of
success and is there a gold standard and
how do you plan to measure that well I
mean like the asserted models in one
sense would be a gold standard so being
able to retrieve the known models would
be a way of testing it whether or not
I'm sufficiently grabbing you know the
models that exist I think that's the key
but as far as like doing any other gold
standard tests I'm not entirely sure
that's kind of like one the key ones
though I mean you know there's a lot of
metrics that are used for tests tests
like this like sensitivity specificity
recall and precision although you have
to have a gold standard to kind of know
that you're retrieving the correct model
or is this more kind of generating
hypothesis
these four future researchers to test to
see if those associations are correct or
not right yeah I mean it is more for
hypothesis generation you know just kind
of more of a discovery approach and then
you would follow up with subsequence
like a lab lab result or literature
results or you know the gene may be a
functional interaction Network tests
would be another way of examining them
yes
yeah and oh sorry yeah you have to the
button when you ask but just just
generally what's it oh just generally
you know as in regards to regenerative
medicine you know weather weather what
might be the better models you know for
investigating you know those
regenerative medicine approaches would
it be a mouse or would like a zebrafish
perhaps be you know like a better a
better model to study those types of
injury regeneration approaches and I'm
trying to remember I had what I want to
say that you know like the zebrafish
genome might have more regenerative
qualities I mean like one of the classic
examples would be salamanders you know
that where you can cut off an entire
limb and you know look at getting a full
regeneration of a fully functional limb
so there might be other organisms that
might be more interesting for looking
into regenerative medicine but at the
same time if we want to then and
translate that interpret it to a human
model we may run into trouble unless you
know we can activate the same pathways
that you know are being activated in the
salamander I mean unfortunately we don't
inherently had the same regenerative
properties
yes - nice talk Brian
so how like when you get your results
how do you plan to share it with the
world do you plan to have a database of
these like kind of orthologs or good
good question um I'm not entirely sure
like I fall do like specific sharing of
my thesis work but the end goal although
I didn't really discuss it too much in
my presentation here the end goal would
be to incorporate so the monarch
initiative uses the semantic similarity
techniques use by Allison but it doesn't
currently use the the fina log approach
to identify additional models and
additional gene candidates and the end
goal would be to eventually incorporate
the the fina logs approach to the
monarch initiative and then people could
then examine those those models and
those jean candidates at the moniker
initiative is a website using their
tools aside from that I mean I'll I'll
have all of my code up in github and I
don't know if I'll be creating my own
repository but I mean most like it would
just go through monarch
okay well if there's no further question
do you want me just go ahead and go over
it okay yeah sure sure
so starting off you have the the gene
phenotype associations from the various
model organisms model organism databases
so these these are just be sorry I did
kind of gloss over in this diagram a
little bit the the gene ornithology of
it but basically you'd have the gene
phenotype associations you'd have to use
the the original papers used in paranoid
but monarch uses a panther and we'll
probably just gonna use Panthers
basically identify the the orthologues
between the two species so what's
actually getting provided to the fina
log algorithm would actually be ortholog
phenotype associations specific gene
phenotype associations and that would
allow you to compare the genes across
species by the linking ortholog so that
would go into the go into the phenyl log
algorithm where you would then do that
prep we I'll do human as well and I'll
be looking at all of them I mean and
then for aim one of course I'd be doing
the the zebrafish Mouse and humans and
then for the aim to yep the Wild West at
whatever model organisms I can
incorporate that's correct yes pairs of
phenotypes where there's a significant
phenyl log identify between the two and
kind of like for the previous step you
know where we're using the or the
ortholog is a link between genes
this one we'd be using the FINA log as
links between phenotypes and in that way
we'd be comparing phenotypic profiles
where is that the normal phenyl log
algorithm as used as just just comparing
single phenotype to single phenotype but
in order to compare it to Allison which
compares fingertip profiles we need to
do an extension in order to get to the
same level yeah yeah the the p-values
are adjusted for a false discovery rate
otherwise you have you'd have enrichment
or you'd have a over-over you'd have it
you'd have too many too many results if
you didn't adjust for the fall discovery
rate for multiple comparisons so yes
everything everything from the top down
to that first blue box is the work done
by McGarry and their 2010 paper and then
my proposed extension is everything down
below that yes yes yes would be that it
be the same test and although I didn't
discuss it here this that might be an
interesting spot to look to do
integration of some of the semantic
similarity stuff just because one of the
concerns I have with this approach is
that if we're doing two subsequent
enrichment calculations I'm not sure how
many you know how many significant
models we're gonna get at the other end
since we're already doing you know one
enrichment calculation so I imagine the
number of total models might be small
but I won't know for sure until I run
the tests okay come on did you have a
question yeah so
I mean you'll be going through
significant data sources like going
through multiple organisms so this will
involve many many genes they will appear
in different models and obviously you'll
be looking at like in your second name
like top candidates - but I think in
some ways it might be worthwhile to keep
a lot of that data and actually make it
available as an annotation for something
like a track on the UCSC genome browser
I mean so what's there right now is you
know you can look at for example MGI
qtls map to human there's a few things
like that but I think what you're gonna
build here has the potential to put like
a more complete like comparative
phenotypic s' right on to the software
to annotate it first of all do you know
if such a thing exists and and how would
you go about building such a thing I'm
not sure that something is this I mean I
know for the feet longer work that the
Megerian woods and the two papers that
they've done previously I mean they have
they do have a website available you
know where you can calculate the phenol
logs on the fly using their you you
input your genes of interest in the
organisms and you can get the phenol
logs that you put on the other side but
I'm not sure trying to recall whether or
not they had a kind of like a final data
set on the other end if that was
available I know that the input data set
available and then they can do the
calculations to the web browser but as
far as like a supplying fuel long so the
other approach I mean it'd just be yeah
matter of you know running these
calculations with all of the organisms
that I want to work with and then just
establishing a database or identifying a
existing repository that might house
that but yeah I'm not sure if they have
a existing fee log repository aside from
living logs website but this would be
from a more like a gene and location
specific point of view so you would have
to come up with a way to somehow you
know looking from that perspective you
want to annotate that particular
location like what kind of
models it appears in like which
organisms or maybe you know it's gonna
be even maybe it can appear with your
sort of this matrix comparison it can
appear in models that appear across
multiple organisms right so I guess you
would need to think about a way to to
show that you know useful where right
right yeah correct yeah yeah it's not
working
yeah yeah that seems I could probably be
part of the easiest approach if nothing
else again since we're already hands-on
with it yeah that might be might be the
best route for incorporating
okay well we'll leave you to your thank
you